bon avec nous bien relier pineau au
titulaire de la chaire de gestion du
secteur de l'énergie à hec montréal
pierre olivier pineau bonsoir soir la
réalité que vous présenter de nouveau
cette année dans votre bilan de
l'énergie c'est que le véhicule à
essence et même le gros véhicule à
essence jusqu'à un certain point des
camions légers jusqu'aux plus gros
camion demeure toujours largement
dominant extrêmement dominant depuis 6
ans tous les ans on bat des records de
vente est de plus en plus de camions
légers dans le parc automobile et on
délaisse la voiture la voiture à petites
voitures ne se vend réellement de moins
en moins on en a on en immatriculent de
moins en moins au québec et les gens se
tournent pour des véhicules plus lourds
plus chère et plus énergivore que une
nouvelle voiture
alors malgré tous les discours malgré
toutes les préoccupations
environnementales
malgré les voitures électriques qui
s'ajoutent les bornes et cetera les plus
gros véhicules sont toujours de gros 22
de plus en plus de gros 20 heures oui
même si les véhicules électriques se
vendent effectivement bien davantage
qu'auparavant on a vraiment une petite
petite explosion la deux du marché du
véhicule électrique
mais ça ne compense pas pour les
nouveaux véhicules lourds vs pick up qui
prennent d'assaut le marché
on va regarder quelques-uns des
graphiques que vous avez préparé dans le
bilan du secteur de l'énergie
on va les expliquez vous avez ici
l'évolution depuis 1990 du nombre de
camions et de voitures vendues et donc
au québec est clairement on voit que les
camions ont toujours pris de plus en
plus de place une hausse de 2 163 pour
ça oui c'était marginal en 90 et la
voiture dominé et là on arrive au point
où on vend plus de camions
c'est à dire des camions lourds mais
aussi surtout des v ux des pick up des
femmes que de voitures et depuis 2000 15
ans
moins de voitures les concessionnaires
en vente de moins en moins voyant une
chute du vente du nombre de voitures
vendues alors qu'on a de plus en plus de
camions qui sont sur les routes donc
1990 à 2018 hausse de 2 163 % des
minifourgonnettes des camionnettes
notamment des véhicules utilitaires
sport baisse de 36% des voitures de 90 à
2018 donc on a vraiment une sas et
interchanger en termes de part de 20 du
total des ventes
absolument le le marché vraiment aux
gros véhicule même si il faut le
mentionner on le voit pas très bien les
véhicules électriques prennent une
petite part ici en bas de l'écran c'est
vraiment petit mais ces trois pour ça et
c'est 3% s'agrandit c'est certainement
que c'est une bonne tendance mais
malheureusement ça ne fait rien pour
endiguer ce que parfois j'appelle
l'hémorragie de camions lourds sur
camions lourds et légers sur les routes
québécoises 2ème graphique ce sont les
ventes de produits pétroliers depuis le
total des ventes de produits pétroliers
incluant l'essence ici et seulement les
sens
là on voit dans les deux cas qui a une
progression des ventes de produits
pétroliers jusqu'en 2018 effectivement
l'économie va bien on s'est habitué à
des prix de l'essence assez élevé et
donc même avant on a eu on a eu d une
baisse de la consommation notamment avec
des prix de l'essence qui était très
élevé avant 2008 et 2013
sauf que on s'est habitué les prix même
s'ils ont remonté un peu les
consommateurs se sont habitués et avec
une bonne économie on a acheté des
véhicules ce qu'on vient de voir on veut
utiliser les véhicules et forcément les
ventes d'essence augmente parce qu'on a
plus de vécu et des véhicules plus
énergivores et vous fait une projection
à partir des années 2013 2018 fait une
projection de la tendance donc au rythme
actuel on s'en va vers une augmentation
jusqu'en 2030 de 32%
et oui et ça serait malheureusement
exactement contraire à ce qu'on vit
dans la politique énergétique québécoise
et la politique climatique de réduction
des gaz à effet de serre on vise moins
40 % de ventes de produits pétroliers en
2030 et on devrait donc diminuer mais on
va malheureusement dans le sens inverse
intéressant intéressant ça c'est
vraiment la réalité et la projection qui
se fait sur la réalité
57% des types de carburants utilisés
essence automobile 24% diesel 14%
carburéacteur ça c'est pour les avions
le transport aérien s'est beaucoup
développée et c'est le carburant pour
les avions aujourd'hui au cube 15% des
ventes presque 15% des ventes 2% éthanol
0 3% électricité et dans cette
électricité il faut compter le métro de
montréal qui va occuper une grande part
de cette électricité les voitures
électriques elles prennent de la place
mais ne sont pas encore vraiment
significative dans le bilan général est
donc quand on regarde l'évolution des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
le dernier graphique qu'on va présenter
nos gaz à effet de serre tranquille wind
notre projection et vers le bas mais ça
va pas assez vite par rapport à nos
cibles non nos cibles sont véritablement
d'être 20 % sous le niveau de 90 en 2020
on sait qu'on a raté sept cibles là on
est environ 10 millions de tonnes au
dessus de notre cible voilà il va
falloir faire
un d'énormes efforts pour atteindre en
2030 l'objectif de 54 millions de tonnes
donc on semble l'objectif c'est 54
millions être davantage au dessus de
cela aurait exactement et mais on sait
que pour le climat il faut de réagir
plus vite pour nos objectifs même
d'indépendance énergétique ou de ceux de
briser nos liens avec le secteur
pétrolier il faudrait agir davantage et
la tendance pour 2050 c'est conserva 62
mégatonnes alors qu'on s'est donné un
objectif de 17 mégatonnes c'est une
véritable petite révolution qui va
falloir atteindre dans notre
consommation d'énergie nos systèmes
énergétiques
depuis que vous faites ce bil'in d'année
en année c'est quoi votre constat qu'est
ce que vous remarquez particulièrement
énormément d'inertie on est très heureux
de mettre à jour à chaque année mais
malheureusement on a des conclusions
très similaires qu'est le système ne
bouge pas très vite
il ya des bonnes initiatives qui se
prennent on développe le gaz naturel
renouvelable par exemple et ça on l'a
ajoutée dans le bilan cette année on le
range il est visible statistiquement
visible dans les données énergétiques
évidemment l'électrification des
transports c'est une bonne tendance mais
par en parallèle il faudrait juguler
cette la hausse des ventes de véhicules
à essence et ça on n'arrive pas à le
faire mais on a un système énergétique
qui est très difficile à changer à faire
évoluer et donc il va falloir
sensibiliser la population et des
politiques gouvernementales beaucoup
plus agressif voilà pierre olivier
pineau merci beaucoup encore une fois
pour ce bilan cette année
ça m'a fait plaisir merci